I'm gonna give the team you tell me the
inconvenient truth about this playoff
team and what could hold them back
gotcha the New Orleans Saints the New
Orleans Saints I'll tell you one of the
incan what they've been leaning on well
I will say this I think one of the
inconvenient truths and it's been
exposed a little bit is Drew Brees and
what he can bring to the Saints offense
I know we're gonna open up a can of
worms here what do you want we would but
we don't mention offenses all the time
right how great offenses make you defend
the whole soil but he's not at this age
39 years old he's not capable of
scrambling out of the pocket making
plays that way Monday against Carolina
when the rush got there the play was
over right exactly right he's not gonna
make any physically demanding plays that
we're gonna go whoa there was nobody
open the protection wasn't that great
and he still made it happen and hey
listen he throws the ball shorter
downfield he's tied with Eli Manning for
28th and football yards intended ere
yards yeah him and Eli tied yes so again
they can win the Super Bowl with him yes
there is little issues with his game and
when you see teams take away their
screens and things like that that
offense doesn't work as smoothly because
nobody's scared of Drew Brees throwing
bombs over their head there's one team
that everybody is piling on right now
yeah cuz they're excited they no longer
have a buy right hey treants ooh I'm
still scared of the pitcher yes I you
should put that out right but what is
there inconvenient truth there
inconvenient truth is that Gronk is no
longer the greatest mismatch in football
that has n Gronk is no longer holding
the trophy as the best tight end in the
game and I would even argue that he's
not even Brady's go-to guy all the time
I think there's been big moments during
the year where he's gone I'm gonna go to
Josh Gordon here I trust him in this
situation and since Josh Gordon's been
there he's been targeted more than any
other receiver on their team I want a
real yes Gronk Oh
Gronk has lost a step yeah I do think
he's lost his intensity
yeah and I don't think hey there's a
reason New England was rumored to be
trying to trade him in the offseason
I think they saw a few you know dents in
the armor here that were about to come
about a few more dents in the armor yeah
LA Rams right offense has been
struggling yeah it's the inconvenient
truth about the ramp
people are gonna point to Jared Goff
right they are who's been in struggles
Ville I mean touchdown the
less-than-perfect okay
get that so he deserves some of the
blade but the real inconvenient truth is
the interior part of their offensive
line they got big time issues there and
that's really the biggest reason you've
seen all three of their losses sheldon
Rankin's whooped them for the Saints
okay Eddie Goldman and Hakeem Hicks
whooped them $1 ate them right Fletcher
Cox and you're either whoop there but
this paddle we how that happen that's
the inconvenient truth now they can't
win any of those battles on the inside
the running games not working and of
course pressures getting into golf space
and he's not a sharp either I have one
more inconvenient and it's me to you oh
gosh and I'm a little convenient that I
got to work with you on a daily basis
all right well now I'm not afraid to say
no I can't believe I'm saying this but
he's over my shoulder yeah I don't think
Aaron Rogers the best quarterback in the
NFL anymore well you sound like my son
Phillip who lacks last week was watching
Patrick mahomes on Thursday night and
said my home's better than rounders now
yeah look I'm just happy that one Sims
in the family has some sense but I think
that Patrick mahomes is far and away get
out of this get out of this duty line
this is blasphemy
my thesis second shrine in here
blasphemy where is that of left go who
what where did my host go I'm just
saying he doesn't have Tyree kill he
didn't have Kareem hunt he doesn't have
Andy Reid he doesn't have Sammy Watkins
he doesn't have Travis Kelce Aaron
Rodgers you're still the greatest but
even the greatest needs help sometimes
I am not saying he's worse than two yeah
I'm just saying he's not one it's the
first year I'm not gonna lie I've had
moments I know I've had moments where
I've gone huh
this is getting closer I said huh this
is getting kind of close Wow
but I'm still not gonna give him the
know best part that it was fill up is I
can keep Sims and left go and just
replace you with him I love that thanks
a lot me and next week